Speaker 1: All right, don't worry. We're not
going to spend a ton of time on this. But
I do want to go over the last sort of 24 hours
of reactions from the Trump camp to the January
six Trump Riot Committee hearings were first
going to look at some of the things that Donald
Trump posted to his platform truth, social
truth.
Speaker 3: Central, of.
Speaker 1: Course. And we're also going to
look at a supposed 12 page letter that Trump
wrote. Well, let me say it a different way.
It's a 12 page letter, a 12 page letter that
Trump supposedly wrote. We're going to look
at that as well. So let's start with truth,
essential or truth social. Donald Trump going
absolutely bonkers on his social media platform
about these hearings, starting with, quote,
word out that the reason the UN selects have
canceled Wednesday's kangaroo court is a total
lack of interest, leading to very poor television
ratings. Could this be so? Maybe they should
try getting a more talented Hollywood producer
than the former president of ABC Fake News.
He didn't do so well. So this is a a calculated
talking point from Republicans that nobody
cares about the hearings. Now, of course,
it's not true. Listen, it's not the Super
Bowl, okay? We all acknowledge that these
are boring hearings by traditional standards,
although I have found them quite riveting
myself. But there were about 22 million people
who watched the first night of broadcast.
That doesn't include any of the online audiences
which were which were huge. So the audience
has actually been fine. Trump then untruth,
social, saying, quote, Does anybody notice
that the UN Select Committee refuses to discuss
or debate in any way, shape or form the many
irrefutable types of election fraud and irregularities
found in the 2020 election? This is cancel
culture because they know that they have zero
chance of winning that debate. So sad to see
our capital c country falling apart. Now the
opposite is true. In fact, every single allegation
of voter fraud or irregularities has been
significantly refuted. Not only have they
been refuted by Republicans in testimony during
the committee hearings, including from William
Barr and others. Every single claim has been
investigated. Close to 70 such claims were
brought to courts, and the courts found that
there was no merit or that there was no standing.
I will gladly say some of the courts took
it as a standing issue. Allegations of supposed
dead voters were investigated. The voters
were found alive and well. A handful died
after legally voting absentee, and then they
died by Election Day or by the day that the
investigation was done. There was some junior
senior confusion. It's been investigated.
Massive dumps, as Donald Trump likes to say.
You know what?
Speaker 5: That big, massive dumps.
Speaker 1: Yeah, big, massive dumps of voting
votes in boxes are being brought in overnight.
It's been looked at. It's been widely debunked.
All of these claims have actually been refuted.
And so Donald Trump just lying there. Trump
then posting to Truth Social, the UN Select
Committee refused to debate the election results.
The reason for the massive crowd on January
six because they camp and again they are in
the position of wanting something unreasonable.
We have election results. Election results
are not something we debate. We don't say,
hey, you know what? We I believe that a flat
tax is best for the economy. And you believe
a progressive tax is best for the economy.
Let's debate it and each bring forward our
perspectives and historical evidence. No,
no, no. We we counted the ballots and Joe
Biden won when there have been audits or recounts
done. Joe Biden won. That's it. It's there's
there's nothing to debate as far as that goes.
Then Donald Trump posting the other selects
are going against me because I am the only
one who can fix our endangered country and
they want to destroy it. People want to go
back to where we were just two years ago.
Again, the weaponised narcissism. Only I can
fix it. All of the things Trump told us he
would fix during his presidency, he did not
fix. And then Trump also attacking William
Barr. William Barr, who, by the way, still
said he would vote for Trump over a Democrat
in 2024. For all of the criticism that Barr
has levied against Trump, he still said, Oh,
I'm not going to vote for a Democrat. If it's
Trump versus a Democrat in 2024, I'll vote
for Trump even though he said that. Trump
is furious with Barr because Barr said, Yeah,
all of these claims are B.S. and Trump posting,
quote, former Attorney General Bill Barr,
a RINO, if there ever was one, a.
Speaker 3: RINO named Mitt Romney.
Speaker 1: Era. Yeah. A RINO means Republican
in name only. He didn't have the stamina or
courage to go after vote for. Rod was afraid
he was going to be impeached. No guts, no
glory. So Trump turning on William Barr as
well, really losing it. Now, these things
Trump definitely did right. What we're going
to look at next, I don't
believe Trump wrote